ننوه مشاهدينا مره اخرى لهذا الخبر العاجل
بحسب اذا يدعو تحر نوت اغلاق عدد من
المستوطنات في الجليل بسبب تحذيرات من
اطلاق صواريخ مضاده للدروع من لبنان
للمزيد من التحليل العسكري والاستراتيجي
معنا الان من رام الله اللواء الركنه
المتقاعد واصف عريقات الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه
والعسكريه ارحب بك معنا دعنا نبدا ربما
بهذه التصريحات لابيد يقول فيها بانهم يتم
الوصول الى مسؤولي حماس ويقول ايضا بحسب
صحيفه معاريف ان الثقه المفقوده بين
القيادتين السياسيه والامنيه العسكريه
تعوق تحقيق الاهداف المعلنه من قبل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه هل من قراءه في هذه
التصريحات
عسكريه يعني بالتاكيد حينما يعجز الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن تحقيق اهدافه على الارض وفي
مواجهه المقاومين الفلسطينيين يلجؤون الى
الحرب الناعمه وهي الحرب التي يمكن من
تنفيذها عن بعد سواء كان بالطائرات او
بالاغتيال او بالخدعه وهذا هذا تعبير عن
عجز الجيش الاسرائيلي في الميدان يعني
نلاحظ انه الحرب البريه وبعد مرور اكثر من
شهرين وهناك 100000 جندي اسرائيلي تمددوا
توغلوا تسللوا صحيح ولكنهم حتى الان غير
قادرين على تنفيذ الاهداف سمعنا من الجيش
الاسرائيلي اهداف ك القضاء على المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وتحرير الاسرى الرهائن في
القوه العسكريه لم يحققوا اي من الهدفين
تعدلت الاهداف نحن نعرف انه يمكن تعديل
الخطط العسكريه تبعا ل يعني تطور هذه
العمليات ولكن ان ان تعدل الاهداف وتعدل
جذريا يعني من من من من اهداف سقفها عالي
الى اهداف متدنيه لدرجه انهم يبحثون عن
هويات لقيادات يبحثون عن هويات لقيادات
فلسطينيه ويبحثون عن فتحات انفاق ويبحثون
عن معلومات من خلال اعتقال اكبر عدد ممكن
من الشباب والنساء الفلسطينيين من اجل جمع
المعلومات هذا كله تعبير عن عجز لذلك هم
يتوجهوا الى مثل هذه التهديدات وتنفيذ
العمليات طيب هويد لا يتحدث على ان
المشكله في الاهداف ويقول ان الوضع الراهن
يقتضي كما يقول علاجا مختلفا في نظام سلاح
الاحتياط وتغيير الموازنات الماليه وزياده
ايضا حجم الجيش عددا وع هذا ما يقول
يعني بالتاكيد لبيد لا يستطيع ان يقول او
ربما يتجنب القول بانه الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي هزم يوم
1 في عمليه طوفان الاقصى بحاجه الى اعاده
هيكله و بحاجه الى اعاده تاهيل وما يجري
على ارض الواقع يعني استمرار للهزائم بعد
17 لذلك الكيان الصهيوني الذي يرتكز على
القوه العسكريه يعني هذا ضرب ضرب يوم 1
وما زال كل يوم يضرب وهذا ينعكس على كل
البنيه في الكيان الصهيوني البنيه
السياسيه
والاقتصاديه وكل شيء في الداخل الاسرائيلي
يجب ان يعاد هيكلته ويجب ان يعاد تاهيله
وهذا طبعا نتيجه صمود الشعب الفلسطيني
واحتضانه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه التي برعت
وتبرع في كل يوم في مواجهه الجيش الاس
وافشال فبالتالي الحرب الان يعني تنتقل من
الميدان العسكري الى مرحله يعني الى حرب
على الوعي الوعي الان في الداخل
الاسرائيلي بان الجيش الذي لا يقهر قهر
وان الحكومه الاسرائيليه عاجزه عن اداره
دفه الحكم وان هناك مقاومه فلسطينيه وان
هناك شعب فلسطيني يحتضن هذه المقاومه يعني
هناك مواقف قويه فلسطينيه وهناك مواقف ضعف
اسرائيليه هذهه هي المعادله ام الموجوده
الان وهي لا تخفى على احد حتى الحليف
الامريكي اصبح يدرك ذلك ويتحدث بهذه
اللهجه في البيت الابيض انهم يساندون
الجيش الاسرائيلي والجيش الاسرائيلي غير
قادر على تنفيذ اهداف على الارض وهذا
ينعكس على كل الواقع الاسرائيلي ويجعلهم
يتخبطون لذلك نشاهد عدم قدره في اتخاذ
القرار باي باي اتجاه امم ننوه فقط لهذا
الخبر العاجل بحسب مراسل الجزيره الجيش
الاسرائيلي اذا يواصل قصفه والان المدفعي
الكثيف على جباليه وشمالي قطاع غزه يعني
اعود اليك يعني كان هناك حديث من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي بان الوضع معقد جدا في
خان يونس يعني بحسب تحليلك ومتابعتك ما
الذي يجعل هذا الوضع والمعارك في خانيونس
تحديدا بهذا التعقيد وهذه
الصعوبه يعني بالتاكيد هو التعقيد الاساس
هو المقاوم الفلسطيني وبسالته وقدرته
ومهاراته الميدانيه واستعداده واعدا ده
للمعركه بشكل جيد استغلاله لنقاط قوته وهي
كثيره يعني هو الان يتحكم بطبيعه الارض
ويعرف عدوه يشاهد عدوه في حين ان العدو
الاسرائيلي لا لا يعرف اين اهدافه حتى
الان يحاول جمع معلومات عن الاهداف سواء
كان قدرات المقاومه او المقاومين او
الانفاق او اي اي قدرات قتاليه اخرى
فبالتالي هذا العماء عند الجيش الاسرائيلي
يضعفه اضافه الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي
هزم يوم سب عش وجاء الى قطاع غزه مسكونا
بالهزيمه ومسكو بالصدمه اي ويحمل عقيده
هني بعل انه قادم الى قطاع غزه اما اسيرا
او قتيلا اي وحينما واجه المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين في الميدان وشاهد بسالتهم
وقدرتهم على ال على القنص وعلى نصب
الكمائن على اصابه الدبابات المتحركه كل
هذه ضربت روحه المعنويه والقتاليه سنكتفي
بهذا شكرا لك من رام الله لواء الركن
المتقاعد
f